what's up you limp gymnast huh your
little propecia attics you busting up a
balsa haircare pills in the back alley
Oh catch a gram of that to the dome Oh
check that mop
daddy's fro looks fuller don't it we're
talking rest in peace Living Hope
West Coast wedding six years without sex
saying goodbye to a friend saying hello
to ourselves my Barry bear was never the
same after he got hit by that icicle he
could have gone pro no he couldn't
welcome to this past weekend this past
weekend good to be home
[Music]
good morning
start your day off with a healthy
balance
Meo celebrate man
[Music]
it's Sunday October 8th that's when I'm
starting this thing but you know what
I'm gonna finish it Monday October 9th
so it's gonna be hot off of the press
for you guys thank you guys for joining
me I really appreciate it
welcome to this past weekend I want to
tell you that I I was in Oregon for this
weekend organ that's the Northwest and
that is tree country cheddar cheese
country do you know that got there slang
in that that uh that dirty a dare a yeah
no DUP they're slinging cheese man and
you have to think about when you when I
think about that when I just think about
the fact they got a company up there
called Tillamook Cheese and if you go to
the grocery store you can see it it's in
like the fancy section you know like
they have all the regular cheese it's
all kind of like orange colored and
looks like it was beaten maybe by some
of its you know parents or looks like it
was maybe jumped by a carton of eggs or
something you know it looks like maybe
it was like kind of like the chubby
cousin that nobody ever like talked to
at the party for a couple decades they
got that area with those big blocks of
cheese and they got the slices you know
and those cheese's all stacked up you
know and a lot of a lot of you see some
time when I was young if we wanted a
snack mom would give us a hit us with
that slice of cheese you know kind of
debt you know sometimes even if they
only had one if they only had one slice
left in the house and she liked one of
us children more than the other she'd
kind of come over in a slide that hit
you with that slice you know or drop it
in the back eat a t-shirt you know what
is that a snack you know my mother had
like little tricks up her sleeve like
that and she would drop like a little
hit hit you with that chilli slices she
down the back of your shirt you know
just what is that cheddar just slide
that uh that cheese sliced down the
vecchia's shirt and you knew that you
were the good child you knew that you
were the the love child
for that moment in time you know you
fell you know and it was just a good
snack it was a good snack of cheese you
can break it off you can cut it into
squares one thing I like to do was make
a like a little like make like put five
little holes in it and try to put my
hand through it and make almost like
I'll put my fingers through the cheese
and almost make like a brass knuckles
out of it and then just cheese check one
of my sisters and my brother you know
just cheese check them right in a chance
and cook our mom loves me more
you got cheese check brother you know
I'm having coffee I'm having coffee guys
good morning or good afternoon or good
whenever you choose to consume this
that's up to you
but I am making it on on October 8th and
October 9th and I was in Portland Oregon
for a wedding this weekend and I'm gonna
get to a lot of things man I'm gonna get
to a few things got some emotional
things that kind of happened this
weekend but I just want to start off
with you know I'm just thinking about
love man I'm thinking about love you
know and that might sound a little bit
gay or a little bit tender but you know
sometimes we have to think about it you
know sometimes we have to put love at
the forefront of our mind because we
almost sometimes use it as a tool in
passing I find you know I you know I see
my my brother or my niece you know and I
tell them I love them you know I tell
them what they mean to me you know I
love you you know I let them know I love
them sometimes I let them know more
pertinently and sometimes I just say it
but we just use it as a as a social
media tool as well my love you know we
use it at the end of a letter sometimes
almost as if it's something I find that
I use it as if it's something that I
remember it being used in the past from
one of my parents
from a friend or whoever you know a
stepparent who sent me a card or a gift
and they meant it you know so I almost
use it as a traditional you know it's
almost like oh well you of course if
it's a family member you finish off the
letter with you know love so-and-so but
I wonder a lot sometimes if we're if
we're practicing it you know I wonder if
I'm practicing it and for me personally
it's hard sometimes you know I think I
grew up person without a lot of
reflections of love out there you know
and so so for me I can feel it sometimes
but then I have to go forth and actually
make an effort to practice love and and
you can do that in a lot of different
ways there's a million opportunities a
day to do it you know and we're gonna
get into some of that but it's got
emotions on my on my heart sleeves I
think a lot of us do you know right now
I went up to Portland Oregon this
weekend I went to a wedding you know I
had a beautiful date that took me up
there and it's a gal that you know I
spent some time with and so she took me
up there to this Portland Oregon and now
if you haven't been up there they have
clean air right when you get there oh
man
I'll do another Eightball of this you
know I'll do I'll hit I'll hit another
couple of lines of Mother Nature's fresh
breath you know break me off a couple of
grams of that atmosphere you know I'm
saying I'm feeling flipped and the air
is so fresh you almost you catch a buzz
man you know like if I see somebody
breathing heavy I'm like damn this
dude's getting [ __ ] up
he's getting cracked off out here and it
was nice man and the first thing that
got me up there was the weather because
for some people you know the weather is
starting and you know me I'm a proponent
of early holidays I'm already dude I'm
ready for Christmas you cannot even tell
right outside of the studio I have my
stockings up
fire I'm ready I like the holidays you
know I love them and in Los Angeles a
lot of people celebrate a lot of people
do not have any joy in their heart so
they choose not to celebrate but I like
to keep the spirit alive but I was in
Oregon and I noticed the weather man it
was getting crispy and I was asking does
it snow here and they said well
sometimes you know and it made me think
back to the first time I've ever snowed
in my town and I was playing basketball
you know I was on one of these regionals
you know 11 and 12 year old boys
basketball team just [ __ ] and I remember
playing three quarters one time with the
hardest boner you ever seen dude I mean
I they almost technical fouled me do
just for playing too close to defense
you know saying I was being a pervert I
can't help it if you got my blood
running out here on this sporting event
and daddy's gonna pop off a little in
the crotch at the same time you know if
this dude don't want to get touched by
daddy tell him to go around something to
beat me to the hoop cuz I can't help it
if I'm out here erect playing a little
bit of defense that's where I'm from I'm
from the streets somewhere I bring my
dick to the party all right I'm a man
and and I remember playing basketball
and this was that just that time you
know when everybody was just the
erections and pimples you know just
little pockets of sebum just their pores
all filled up with dirt and their
wieners all just filled up with blood
and erection juice and sauce or whatever
it is whatever however you make it up
that's up to science that's not my job
but I remember it's snowed and it had
been cold cold for two days and there
been ice and stuff and at halftime when
one of our basketball games it snowed
and literally we came out of the tunnel
from the halftime like you know you go
in the back and the coaches you know
yelling and drinking and stuff and and
the players are just kind of relaxed and
you know or whatever just being you know
twelve years old and we came out on the
whole gym was empty and that's because
it snowed outside
and people were just bananas they were
bonkers over this new atmosphere you
know it was just it was like the first
time you ever seen a magic show but like
the world was putting the show on for
you you know it was like mother nature
was just like aha and it was snowing you
know we never seen this I mean we're
talking about the heat of rural
Louisiana you know we're talking about I
remember just I saw one time a snake in
the air in the air dude you know I saw a
raccoon one time sweating sweating you
know trying to drink a Gatorade this
before they had Powerade when they just
had Gatorade and so you know where
everyone next thing you know everybody's
out in the snow and everybody's having a
good time and there was one boy in our
town dude and I don't know how this [ __ ]
you know this [ __ ] dude I mean anyway
these people was kept pretty you know
white trash really you know and I'm no
stranger to it man I'm 50 percent white
trash myself but these people had gone
on a full 100% tile you know they'd gone
all the way in and the boy got hit by a
a icicle and I don't know how okay the
odds but it I mean this thing lit him up
you know it was just like a rocket and
we'd had some stuff happen like this in
our area
you know galactically we had one kid I
remember when I was really young got hit
by a meteor took off his arm or part of
his side and people you know there was a
lot of questions about that
some people say his daddy hit him with
the car but you know the family the the
story that's that that ended up winning
out was that he got hit by a meteor and
that's you know and if he did get if his
dad did him with the car than they you
know that's between their family but
what they said was that it was a meteor
and now they had now and the here's the
crazy part is a meteor hit their yard so
you know it's not like there was zero
meteors
and they were just saying they had you
know proof of meteor meteor meteors and
anyhow so but this but this boy Barry
bear was this boy's name ba RR ie and
then the last either ba ye are something
Barry bear and he got hit by a damn
icicle and his mom and he was [ __ ]
something's wrong with that dude I mean
he was never you know they didn't put
all the [ __ ] you know they they
didn't put all the uh the cinnamon in
his biscuit if you know what I'm saying
he I mean you'd have to you some of them
yet it tap him on the shoulder to remind
him to breathe that boy was just damn
ignorant you know it was like somebody
had just broken his damn skull open when
he was little and just snacked on
whatever was in there and then just
closed it up and forgot to put anything
else back in there that boy was coming
in light you know yet almost yeah but
you really almost had to pat him on the
back remaining a breather if we were
running something you have to remind him
we were running because he'd start
walking fast and just not know how to
switch gears something's wrong with his
mental transmissions what I'm gonna say
but he went outside running whatever
[ __ ] wandering around who knows what the
[ __ ] he was up to this little this
little this little fella called an
icicle man and his mom since that day
okay since that day of when Barry bear
hit that icicle and I remember his
family had his truck and they had on the
relations plate says you know they had
bear was her last name said like a
license plate says seven bears because I
had seven bears in the family you know
seven children or whatever and they used
to drive them all to church at the same
time and file out of this van just like
little Pentecostal dang you know like
Pentecostal clowns but his mother is
always complained sin saying hey my boy
you know he was never like this he would
have he was gonna go all the way you
know she'll say [ __ ] like that she's
just always complaining about that
icicle he was gonna he could have gone
pro she'll say [ __ ] like that and Barry
didn't even play nothing he could have
gone pro in what being reminded to
breathe
No so that's the thing about mashup but
his mother ever since him been yelling
complaining you know how he could he'd
this and he will you know he would have
invented something I remember yelling
one time at City Hall he would have he
would have invented something what the
[ __ ] are you talking about miss bear you
know it just makes me it makes me mad
I'm getting to a point here I know I'm
tracking here but here's my point he's
over the years sometimes I think that
when I look at their family now and I
see them from time to time I seen him at
the Burger King last time I was home and
on view have you ever been to a Burger
King it's a it's a [ __ ] kind of
masked in this kind of games of Game of
Thrones cartoon kind of environment and
they um but I saw them up there and I
saw just with them sitting by each other
and I could see that she still had in
her head that everything that had gone
wrong in her life had been this icicle
and she was still complained I could
just feel if I went over and talked to
her so you're gonna tell me about it
tell me but that's that sick or that hit
Barry you know say it's sick took him
down y'all could have been out there
y'all with sports players you know
telling us that's what he told us the
basketball team y'all could have been
out there you could have saved him [ __ ]
I'm not a [ __ ] meteorologist you know
what I'm saying about a defense
tactician against cold weather and
against ice and frozen water you know
but when I looked over at them I
remember the last time I saw them and
I'm gonna get to my point is that you
could tell that she just been
complaining about this and whatever
relationship she was gonna have with her
son you could tell it had kind of lost
cuz I don't remember her being like that
as much before you know I remember being
a little bit silly and but I remember
her being a little bit more calm but
instead of choosing to didn't really
embrace her son and embrace what was
going on she chose to just shout about
it you know and a complain and a damn
just be [ __ ] he could have gone pro
he didn't play anything ma'am
you know what the [ __ ] you talking about
you know and it just it just seemed like
it when I looked over at them I felt
like she was missing out on an
opportunity to to care about her son to
have a relationship with him because I
look that I shook him I'm not gonna lie
to you do cut in knew him shook him only
icicle I've ever seen and you know from
what I hear pretty decent pretty decent
size you noticed like a dam like a real
skinny skinny frozen shark made out of
water just [ __ ] bit him like in the
back of the neck and the top of the head
and uh and and look you know that's
that's neither here nor there you know
whatever happened but but the choice
she's made miss bear since then has been
to complain and it just griping all the
conversations I kind of you know I
remember seeing there around her they're
all about company could you know this
and that and the blame and point fingers
but what she's missing out on to me and
this is just my perception okay I don't
have to be right but to me it looks like
she's miss out on missing out on an
opportunity to love her son and so
that's what sometimes you know uh anyway
so I'm gonna bring this together guys
I'm gonna bring this together bear with
me but I remember that you know and I
remember that's one of the first things
I remember about frozen weather and cold
weather and then I met this weekend and
you know when I met this wedding and you
see they got beautiful examples of love
out there you know I mean just beautiful
examples of love you know and I've never
honestly I never likes going to weddings
you know I think God I'm really when I
was younger I didn't I didn't believe in
it honestly to me it seems stupid it
seems stupid to people can get married
Oh what are you gonna do huh you know go
home together
you know oh everything's gonna work out
okay you're gonna have a fireplace you
know what are y'all gonna have recipes
and everything and everything's gonna be
okay
you know I think some of that's just cuz
growing up you get wild you know if your
environments wild you get wild
and your brain gets wild and your heart
doesn't have any trust in it you know in
your hearts more of a brain than it is a
than it is a heart and that's trouble
sometimes you know when your heart wants
to think because your heart is supposed
to feel you know your hearts are
supposed to feel and and I was at this
wedding man that was beautiful
you know I saw they had a
father-daughter dance and they get out
there and they're hugging and and my
date her sister was getting married and
so I'm right there in the thick of it
you know I'm right there I'm like
sitting by the day while they have the
thought uh father-daughter day I'm
trying to like I mean like how do I act
at a marriage you know like do I you
know I almost wanted to hold up a sign
that said like 88.5 you know three you
know cuatro stars like I was like I
didn't know if I'm like I had to turn
off certain parts of me that wanted to
judge I wanted to act out that wanted to
you know spray mace I remember being at
a party when I was young and I lit that
room up with a hit a mace while nobody
was looking and until you've seen about
thirty thirty just white trash people
just uh you know dance to some NWA
and some day is up late I'm a while
crying at the same time son you really
haven't seen life okay and that's how I
remember setting it off at a party but
here you had people loving each other
man this wedding didn't have any cake I
thought that was odd you know and that
shook me out of the beginning but you
know I just had to I just had to be
patient I did relax and I did not act
out man you know I find sometimes when I
get around instances of like a lot of
love some time my choices to act out you
know instead of to embrace what's going
on but this week and I felt pretty good
about myself because I chose to just sit
there and watch people just you know
fall in love you know I brought some
gummi bears to the reception or to the
UM actual wedding hit this old dude up
next to me with a pack of hurry boughs
bro had that dude been off about 40
bears do
it had that had that do bent out of
shape bruh a couple of them was ahead a
little bit of extra in them you know so
I had this dude straight up kneeling
dude kneeling he could have caught that
but bouquet in his mouth dude this dude
was getting lifted while he was turning
into a dolphin man had that dude lit lit
lit lit man burning his grits but yeah
man I saw a lot of love so I saw a lot
of love this weekend and and it was nice
man in Portland's beautiful area if you
ever get to go up there and I want to
tell you guys right now I still got a
couple or stories a couple things I'm
gonna talk about but I want to tell you
right now that this Tuesday night in Los
Angeles I'll be at the Hollywood improv
with some beautiful friends of mine man
the powerful Joe Rogan is going to come
out mr. Nick Swardson is going to come
out
Dave Wiesel is gonna come out Fahim
Anwar Jimmy shin and myself and and I'm
really excited about that
I'm really excited what else man we're
not we don't have already on today we
don't have him on today still kind of
figuring that out I know you guys have
got a couple thoughts about him before I
crack into a few more stories I just
want to listen to a couple of you guys
as quick thoughts real quick on alright
here we go
mark fuhrman do the mark from Kansas I
just want to call you and tell you about
how much Ari sucks get him off of the
podcast Wow mark being vocal let's go
about it the way that you are speaking
today with the reason I call like gasps
is that we had that other guy on there I
haven't heard him say anything funny at
all on worth what up Theo Tyson I just
want to say I love Ari on the show I
from Georgia right now I'm just driving
to pick up a little bit of Kalani pins
at my brother's house over here up on
the way back and enjoy the rest you show
it's funny of you holla Kalon happens at
your brother's man
that now that's an early Christmas man
if you're over there in Georgia that's
an early Christmas Eve you already
popping into some klonopins eat your
brothers kalana pans have hit my family
hard over the years and I'll say that
I'll out right in vocal and I'm not
gonna point any fingers or anything like
that and I'm not gonna even point all
those fingers away from myself but they
have hit my genetics over the years and
I know that they've done that to a lot
of people I want to talk about a few
more things man
I mean I also want to tell him to be in
Huntsville Alabama in two weeks or in
three weeks November 14th through 16th
that's actually like six weeks away so
but come on out that's it stand up live
but I want to talk about I want to talk
about this this uh this Las Vegas man I
want to talk about this for a minute
because I know it's been on everybody's
hearts and there's some people you that
you're tired of hearing it well I just I
want to I've been trying to think of why
you know I've been trying to think of
why you know I mean you had this fella
and I thought a lot about it man and and
what I come to is this conclusion you
know you have this guy Steven paddock
right and some things about him if you
don't know I mean I know you know about
it but uh he in 1960 his father when he
was seven his father went to prison for
a series of bank robberies right his
father was a bank robber a famed bank
robber and apparently the family knew
nothing about it and surely if they were
children they didn't know you don't have
a perception of that I doubt at that age
but suddenly one day you know the feds
showed up and popped his father and that
was it he went to prison he was on the
FBI's ten most wanted fugitives list
right so that happened him when he was
young it was just something that
occurred in his life some of his jobs he
was a postal worker and a tax auditor
okay pretty stressful jobs I feel like
and notorious for stress those jobs
these days everything is but those jobs
certainly right he had a couple failed
marriages you know love didn't really it
didn't seem to be his strong suit okay
now you've seen interviews with his
brother his brother seems if you haven't
seen his brother seems like all over the
place
you know um disconnected his brother
seems disconnected you know we had two
failed marriages and he did a lot of
gambling tens and hundreds of thousands
of dollars a month he would live in
casinos for a month at a time and
playing video poker that's extremely
disconnected when you think about it you
know here's a disconnected man love
isn't working for him he made a lot of
money he made a lot of money in real
estate he worked hard I had a couple of
different jobs worked hard and then
ended up making a lot of money in real
estate here in California millions he
was a millionaire I made enough money
where his mother didn't have to work and
his brother didn't have to work if he
chose not to apparently these all
sources you know and also he had an
instance in his life where one of his
buildings was during the riots in Los
Angeles in the 90s one of his buildings
was in an area where they were expecting
there could be a lot of looting and he
went on top of his building this is
Steven paddock the Las Vegas shooter he
went on top of his building in a flak
jacket with a gun and protected that
building was up there just ready to
protect we must protect his house he was
ready he was ready to protect his house
so he had that in him you know he had
that he got this weird taste of probably
power of what it was like to be on top
of a building in a flak jacket you know
king of his domain he owned the building
and you know possibly willing to shoot
someone you know at that time I'm saying
to protect whatever he thought was his
so there you have it man you got this
lady that he had this Mary Lou whoever
she is she sounds to me she sounds
docile she sounds just kind of like a
pawn you know maybe a fixture it was a
sweet woman not a bad woman probably a
great woman you know he's probably
catered to his demands and and it seems
like when I start to look at this guy
that that he catered more towards the
dark sides of his life you know you know
I'm sure within his father went away it
was probably really tough really really
tough you know just to not have that you
know to not be able to find
love you know to know your that his
father had chosen this other thing it
was more important than him this this
criminal life and and then you start to
look at his life and he couldn't make
marriage work didn't have any love man
there's no love coming in this man's
life he was sitting in front of video
poker he was already a millionaire
so they where was his desire you know
what you're a millionaire where's your
desire you know if you don't have any
love if there's nothing you're looking
to spread or to create and and then I
think it was to me III could imagine
there was this part of him in
conjunction with the father being a
criminal and there's there's a lot of
rumor out there that it can be genetic
you know there's not a ton of proof but
there's more proof than there is not
proof you know I think there's a study
that I've read where if you have a
family member who is a criminal you're I
think four times more likely to be
involved in some sort of crime now who
knows what you know what group they took
that from but anyhow you have this guy
so you have paddock you have the crime
you have you have the father as the
criminal you have him with no love in
his life you know he had no love man and
he was water in the dark sides of his
life you know he was choosing to give
light to the gambling sitting there in
front of a video poker machine it is
it's almost you can feel how it gets
sick after a while you're just pressing
a button and it's meaningless especially
if you're already a millionaire what are
you even trying to do really when you
think about what are you trying to
accomplish you don't even care if every
you know you're losing tens to a hundred
thousand dollars and what you don't even
care
imagine how just brainless that must
have been and so this dark part of him
was growing you know this dark part of
him was growing and I think he was just
a perfect storm for something like this
to happen you know I think he was a
perfect storm you know 300 years ago
some guy runs into a building with a
knife and stabs three people
this is the modern-day equivalent of
that you know this is that now you know
and I think he just was this perfect
storm of of just lovelessness ego may he
go maniacal they said he had a lot of
ego he'd been living for years probably
as a millionaire gambling so nothing
money there was no just purposeless you
know this this small element that his
father was a criminal you know this
thing inside of him that probably maybe
always made him wonder if he was to be a
criminal I think every boy a little bit
wants to be like their father or thinks
they are like their father no matter
what so that seed in him of darkness
well of that seed with know if that seed
were on a teeter-totter that dark seed
there's nothing on the other side of
that totter you know all his Teeter is
the Dark Arts and there's no totter you
know there's no totter and I think that
that's why it happened
I think that's why it happened man and I
know that's not a lot of a reason but
for me there's that's a lot of reason
you know that that it's you know he just
he didn't water the love side of his
life and I feel I don't feel like that
in my life like I'm at that extreme but
at all
at all let me say I know sometimes I
just you know kind of tail off at the
end of sentences but you got a water the
other side of your life you have to
water the other side of your life okay
I'm not saying that everybody's going to
end up being a shooter or a killer but I
am saying that this is your life
okay and your brain is powerful it's a
computer okay and things can happen to
it if you don't take care of it you know
and that's the thing we you have to take
care of the good parts of your life you
have to you know you have to fight
against the dark arts that are inside of
you
you know what they and I think that it's
our job then that the toughest part is
if you are somebody that feels loved and
feels like your life has love in it then
if you feel that something is wrong with
someone else I believe you have a
responsibility to ask them to ask them
how they're feeling [ __ ] how people are
thinking I am sick of how people are
thinking right how are they feeling
because thinking is cool right but that
[ __ ] thinking is a not more powerful
than feeling okay I was reading
yesterday that you cannot feel love and
think hate you cannot feel love and
think hate do you know that but you can
think love and still feel hate so what
I'm saying is that feeling wins and I
you know and maybe over the years if
some man would some people would have
checked in with this man enough and
asked him how do you feel what's going
on how do you feel because people ask
you that enough and you're gonna melt a
little and you're gonna share it and I'm
not you know I'm not putting the
responsibility of this man of course the
man was mentally ill the man was his
father was
I think declared a psychopath you know I
mean who knows you know at what level of
illness this man was at obviously I mean
he was the Andrea Gail really and I'll
say it again that this was just a
perfect storm you know Mark Wahlberg
couldn't have saved us you know but if
you got love in you man and you got you
gotta you gotta share that [ __ ] you know
I know that stuff's I know it sounds a
little bit you know no homo or anything
like that you know what I'm saying but
you got to share that [ __ ] ask people
how they [ __ ] feel because asking
people what they think that ain't doing
it anymore that's not getting us in him
anywhere you know we got to ask each
other how we feel man and I know I got a
lot of this on me too like you know a
lot of people know that Ralphie May
passed away
a friend of mine you know in Ralphie and
I we weren't best friends I don't want
to put that out there but when I was
around Ralphie he made me feel good on
purpose he did it on purpose some people
it's an accidental thing but Ralphie
made me feel he made me feel cared about
you know and it's almost hard for me to
say a little bit dude you know sometimes
in my life man I'm so used to I got so I
got so used as a child to not feeling
cared about that it is hard for me to
admit as an adult when I am cared about
when someone does care about me and it's
not even a choice really that I'm making
well now it is now if I start to have
that feeling I have to be vulnerable and
you know and honor the fact that I know
someone cares about me but you know for
years I had to read I couldn't even feel
if somebody cared about me I couldn't
even feel it as baffling isn't it I
could not even feel it and I know this
is kind of like a lot on this episode
man but it's I mean [ __ ] man we out here
in these streets you know we are out
here in these streets all right let me
uh let me tell you guys I got to run
into a comedy store set I'll be back in
in just a few minutes but uh for you
guys we're just gonna go right to the
next moment all right all right before
we move on I want to let you know that
there is a way you can support the show
its patreon patr yo in.com slash theof
on th e o vo in you can go there and
support the show there will be extended
footage from episodes that is available
on patreon and thank you to our patreon
supporters who helped us to get our own
new camera that you guys are seeing
today on YouTube so that's really really
exciting and I'm very grateful to you
guys for that support as well there's a
tor shirt that has all the cities from
this past ham panini Z tour and that the
dates are all listed on the back the
cities and in the front is like a new
theof on type of logo I'm not trying to
speak about myself in the third person
I'm just trying to describe to you what
the shirt is like you can check it out
for yourself and that's at theof on comm
slash store sto re I'm sorry two hot
goods but you know what I got to stay in
business dude I got to stay in business
and I got to uh and I got to stay in
business I'm gonna I'm gonna hit the hit
some calls right here you guys had a
bunch of great calls and one of them
that's uh catching it in my heart really
we're gonna catch right here yeah
[ __ ] a be calling from Las Vegas
Nevada calling uh give you my
condolences on Ralphy hey brother I know
he was a good friend of yours and I hope
you dealin and staying positive with
good lord I just want to get my prayers
out to you and that roughly means family
my condolences brothers god bless love
you stay up love the podcast me and the
fam it love you to every man appreciate
the call for those of you guys who don't
know which I'm sure aren't very many
Ralphie May and this is a behalf of the
New York Times a loud and large comedian
known for his extensive touring and
comedy specials on Netflix and other
outlets died Friday in Las Vegas he had
been in a residence at Harrah's Casino
he was 45 years old mr. May born Ralph
Duren May On February 17th in 1972 in
Chattanooga Tennessee was a 17 year old
student in Arkansas when he won a
contest to open for Sam Kinison and
that's where it all began he moved to
Houston then to become a full-time
comedian working the circuit for
years and Ralphie may work the circuit
like nobody else you know at first I
didn't really know what to think
whenever I heard that Ralphie had passed
away I mean obviously I was sad but it's
kind of it's wild because the sadness
it's really I mean at first I felt
scared because it reminded me that life
ends you know that even if you're
somebody like Ralphie May who was out
bringing joy to people and you know and
responding to his fans on Twitter and
interacting I mean for a guy who
couldn't move very well physically he
stayed mobile in the way that he
interacted with so many people and a lot
of on social media and but just his
touring you know he wanted to be there
he wanted to meet his fans and see his
fans and and it's pretty it's just it's
an interesting dichotomy because he was
immobile you know physically he wasn't I
mean you weren't gonna catch him playing
soccer you know so just amazing that he
stayed touring as a way like his to keep
him mobile in a way but he was just one
of the nicest guys you know he always
made you feel cared for and he and he
was he was genuine me just knew that he
cared you know a lot of guys in this
business you bump into him you pass them
you interact with them weekly and you
don't know how they feel about you you
know you don't know maybe they don't
care maybe it's just business I mean
it's work but Ralphie it's just amazing
how how he cared about everybody and how
he just I mean the dude was [ __ ] full
of care man it was just remarkable you
know and I remember times where I would
be feeling down about the business or
doubting myself and he would not let me
do it you know he would just remind me
you know that I was
you know like some type of William
Faulkner something he would talk about
her I don't know he would just talk
about the Lord or something just to lift
my spirits up and uh and yeah I mean I
go through waves when I'm thinking about
him and I'm watching his videos and I'll
share a great video below this on the
YouTube that is a link to Bert Kreischer
and Joey Diaz talking about about
Ralphie May but he was a special man and
I'll say this that Earth as we know it
lost a very special man and I cannot
even imagine the wings that the Lord
left to hook to that man if he's gonna
turn him into an angel I mean sweet God
some real pterodactyl type wings and
Ralphie may tweeted a few years ago that
he wanted us if he were ever to pass -
laughs - joke and and that's something
he loved man to keep the joking going so
I appreciate the call I've been still
have a few voice messages going back
with other comedians where we're
interacting and discussing the loss and
just thinking about it
but he was one of a kind and if you
haven't checked out something Ralphie
may stuff he was fearless I mean he
would go into these black rooms and you
could see you can't show fear in these
black rooms in these black comedy rooms
and there were more than a decade ago
and 20 years ago and it was you know
things were maybe a little more separate
or more dust or there were more specific
black comedy clubs but Ralphie May would
be in there I mean and there's a there's
a level of pride as a white comedian or
maybe as any comedian when you can go
into a black an urban if you want to
call it comedy room and and do your job
because there's a different level of
intimidation in there I can't explain it
it's like you are fighting for your life
because I think black people just in
general are more vocal more more verbose
and just generally good entertainers I
mean you take any average black person
and put them up an average white person
and they're probably going
be more entertaining now what facet
that's in who knows but you know I think
that so there's a level of intimidation
as a comedian when you go in there and
you go into an urban room but out
Ralphie loved it there's some great
videos em online where you can check out
and see exactly what he did but I want
to get to some of you guys as calls here
we're just trying to stay in the love
man you know I know that sounds general
and that sounds vague but you know when
I look back and think about just this
weekend of mine you know being at this
wedding and seeing people I mean dude
there were these bride and groom and
sometimes they would say stuff and I'm
thinking to me I'm thinking man it says
some of this stuff seems cheesy but the
reason it seems cheesy is just because
I'm not in touch with my feelings it's
not because they don't feel those things
you know it's my problem
you know it's my issue and it was just
an interesting time for me to see you
know what you know what love looks like
and what it is when people get together
to celebrate it and how weddings are
such an important thing and never really
had that understanding before you know
people I mean it was just I don't know
people are dancing and the music was
ridiculous and man they passed out these
you know they had this little booth
where you could take where you could
take pictures and stuff with the
different you know headdresses and you
know you could put on the Indian
headdress or like a big glasses or you
know a funny nose or whatever and you
could take a picture out there and then
they had this tommy gun dude and next
thing you know they got some dude
running around the dance floor with a
tommy gun and I'm like jeepers it looks
like fun but just not the time for it
not the time for a guy who may have been
me anyhow let's keep it moving all right
let's crack into a few calls here thank
you guys for hitting the hotline this
week let's see what we got on the line
here hey what's up Co this is a calling
from Las Vegas and I'm just calling
about I'm sure he's heard what's
happening out here and
sadness and everything but you know I
had four four people on they'll get shot
and a buddy I know that I've worked with
for three years and got shot in the face
and kill Wow and I'm sorry if some of
you guys weren't expecting maybe this
type of call to be on here this morning
you know maybe it's not what you want to
be hearing but I think it's important to
to kind of see what's going on with some
people in this area if this guy's
willing to call in and I appreciate your
call brother onward but I'm just
wondering man I'm just wondering if
shifters getting too crazy out there is
can you not even go to a concert and
enjoy it with your friends I mean I'm
friends tell me they were running from
bullets
it's just crazy you know can you not
even go see a movie can you not go to
the fair sporting events as well as it's
getting too crazy and you see a [ __ ]
happening every day so I mean it's a
little it's a little more real when it
happens to you yourself and it's just
got me thinking man I appreciate your
call I think it's got everybody thinking
you know but even more so it's got me
feeling you know cuz in your voice yeah
here you know I hear your thoughts I
hear you share your thoughts but I below
that I can hear what you feel man you
know when you feel you know it sounds
like you feel you know a little broken
hearted you know for society obviously
for your your loss and my condolences
for your friend that you lost and your
friends that have you know I cannot
imagine what that's like and I'm you
know I appreciate you calling and you
know bringing this experience a little
bit closer to us as as listeners on this
past weekend and to me you know it like
it just felt this thing this thing for
me felt intense
it just felt heavy you're right are we
safe can we go out can we do things well
here's the thing
what are you gonna do what else you
gonna do you're gonna stay inside you
know and I'm not bringing this just at
you but I'm just saying overall what
else are we gonna do we're just gonna
huddle and hide and not live our lives
we're already locked into our computers
and locked into you know our our phones
and you know we're already becoming
addicted to things were already becoming
less and less human I think this was
just a perfect storm of disaster I don't
think this is going to become a regular
thing you know and I think this is
sometimes the devil lurks man I was
talking with my brother about this this
evening and he's saying well you know
they had that man Ted Bundy you know he
just used that as an example but people
thought that he was a mild-mannered well
you know well-to-do guy women liked him
he seemed normal aloof but normal and
here he was this man was you know a
serial killer
sometimes Satan lurks man you know
people want to say all Satan and this
and that but nobody else has an
explanation except the dark arts got
that man Stevie paddock the dark arts
got that man and all we can do is build
up the love that's in our hearts bro and
pass it on when you see somebody you
catch that feeling that you know
somebody has some struggle or they're
cold or they're rude break that break
that moment bust through that moment
instead of being like man [ __ ] this
person hit him up man come at him even
you know what's called ice cold to come
at a dude in fact what's going on man
are you feeling you feeling something
are you feeling upset what's going on
bruh that's ice cold to me that's the
coldest thing you can do is get real
with somebody you know and I'm not
saying that I'm perfect at this but I am
saying that I recognize it you want to
get real
you know getting really pulling a
[ __ ] gun this dude was a wimp right
getting really you know [ __ ] somebody
up you know bustin a tooth loose getting
real is is hitting catching somebody's
feelings look what's up with your
feelings man what's up with your
feelings or woman you know what's up
with your feelings man how will do you
feel because we can talk about how we
think all day that's just not getting us
anywhere man so I feel like we've got to
start to figure out our own feelings and
as we do we've got to figure out other
you know we have to work together with
others to share ours and get them to
share theirs man another's just sounds
you know vague and stuff but I think
it's real man
I really really think that it's real
we've gotten so caught up and so away
from things that are realistic you know
that we're all living in these almost
little fantasy universes online and in
these little bubbles and on Twitter and
in these you know that we are missing
out on some of the reality we're missing
out on that human connection and when
you get so disconnected and you don't
water those good seeds inside of you
then the dark arts can prevail man and
that's what I think happened in this
scenario thank you for calling sorry
about your friends onward next call hey
Theo von this is your boy Tom from rural
North Carolina damn tom boy what you
eating that electric oatmeal huh where
you getting your oatmeal from a cocaine
dealer yeah
next onward hey man I just wanted to
send you my thoughts and prayers on why
I think people sending their thoughts
and prayers prayers is [ __ ] every
time there's a tragedy like Sandy Hook
Bay it doesn't matter
turn on your your Facebook feed your
everybody's devastated oh man just oh so
shook and so shook so calm and pretend
you prayers gotta go to Starbucks let me
get Starbucks on a semi per discuss
[ __ ] man like I'm so [ __ ] tired
of social media it's just like
everybody's so [ __ ] fake like send
your thoughts and prayers dog you didn't
know a [ __ ] person in Las Vegas now
like I knew one Tom's heated I can tell
you he did Tom I appreciate you
calling you've called before I
appreciate you call him brother well
you're a little bit heated you don't
like the thoughts and prayers let's hear
a little bit more here Tom onward random
chicken snapchat that happened to be
there in Las Vegas had nothing to do
with this
this chick is talking like she got shot
thoughts and man if you're gonna send
someone and then people be like oh I
made this funny stuff Tommy made a
donation like that did you make the
Gladys makes me think you made the
donation just to say I made a donation
if you're gonna do good you do good out
of the goodness of your heart
you helped somebody cross the street you
help somebody wind it down man you're
not like oh man this is a great
situation to show everybody how great I
am well Tom we live in a me universe
right now you know we really do and you
know we live in a universe where we just
get caught into our own worlds where
we're the only person that really exists
and other people are players and when
that disease gets dark enough that
infection gets dark enough I think you
can see things that happen with like
Stevie patty you know where he's popping
off and gunning you know but I'll say
this I'll say this about thoughts and
prayers Tom I thought about this I see a
lot of people on social media right
after these shootings and right after
these tragedies sharing thoughts and
prayers and I do it myself
and other people say oh well this has
you know gun control and this and that
yes we may need some regulations we need
some changes we need some laws okay we
need how effective and helpful will they
be I don't know but as an example would
it be nice maybe to have some different
laws some different regulations sure but
here's why thoughts and prayers helps
immediately because that's what people
want if I'm lying on the ground and I'm
strong I'm been shot been attacked
something I'd be something I'm deficient
in my humanity because of somebody
else's sickness or illness though I
don't want I don't want someone to tell
me oh they unique but as I'm leaving the
universe they should have had better gun
laws
I don't want that I want somebody
sitting there with me praying I want
somebody letting me know that they're
thinking of me I don't want to be alone
and that's what I think it's about
thoughts and prayers no one who's saying
thoughts and prayers is thinking that's
gonna heal the universe no one's
thinking it's going to solve the problem
thoughts and prayers are an immediate
reaction and I think the reaction that
any one should have when there's a
tragedy
I feel like praying is one of the best
things that you can do praying for
somebody else's piece all praying is is
meditating and not thinking about
yourself but I'll tell you this man I'm
sure the families of these people who
were killed in this tragedy the first
thing that they're thinking isn't they
should have different gun laws that's
not the first person they want coming to
their door is you know it wet and
whether they should or not I'm not
saying that but I'm saying that's not
what they want first the first thing
people want I feel like is uh they want
humanity they want some piece of human
touch and that's where the thoughts and
prayers come in so I disagree with you
on the thoughts and prayers Tom but I
appreciate your calling let's catch one
more call here about the Vegas what's
going on this is a calling from
Fredericksburg Virginia thanks for
calling Sean Fredericksburg I've never
been there I don't think but Virginia
one of the states let's hear it I second
commentary I'd like to share yet another
tragedy over on this side of the globe
you know this sounds like it's being
read to me off of a yet another sounds
like something you would write and then
read back to us rather than just speak
straight up but that's okay
you know I understand for some people to
call and leave a voicemail it might be
tough you know and so I understand even
if that is the case but onward can't
even imagine how those who lost loved
ones in Vegas might be feeling right
about now but
half of that man the response I've seen
on social media in the in the news made
me sick [ __ ] people turning this
tragedy into a racial or bipartisan
issue you're saying people out here
saying see white people are terrorists -
the result of white privilege in America
or even people bringing politics into it
like calling out Trump saying you'd
rather be golfing or some [ __ ] rather
than you know tending to the American
people helping out with those in puerto
rican whatever it is then or hillary
clinton using this is a platform to try
to take on the nra right i appreciate
your call here and you're right there's
a lot of this stuff going on first of
all i don't need a president to tell me
everything's gonna be okay that doesn't
mean anything to me you know uh what i I
don't need some people need that [ __ ]
wait I don't get I don't care if mean I
hope that the president has some concern
you know as a human some presidents are
going to be a lot more empathetic than
others are but most of the [ __ ] that all
these politicians say it just comes off
like [ __ ] you know I think a lot of
these politicians are so disconnected
from what regular humans lives are like
you know yeah so I agree I don't I mean
I don't know if I agree or not I can't
even remember where you were exist the
exact point you were making but yeah
people are using it for different
reasons but I don't need my president to
tell me everything's gonna be okay in a
tweet or an announcement I don't that
doesn't do anything for me you know if
there's a that needs to be directed and
the president wants to make an
announcement about that then that's the
bells and whistles you know if the
president wants to say you know in in
light of this tragedy today today is a
great time to to pray for your fellow
Americans sure I think that that's great
if the president wants to share
information on where people can donate I
think that that's great too but I don't
need my president to tell me everything
is going to be okay I mean maybe some
people do I don't need that onward
you know these are friends of mine I see
on Twitter you know talking about this
kind of stuff it's like you know only
better than this you know American
people died citizens our brothers and
sisters died at the hands of an
extremely mentally ill person arrived in
mourning or coming together the reaction
seems to be able to cut deeper into this
division you know I appreciate it man
it's true that's a good point you know
and I don't know I think it's true as we
become more divided how do we get to
that next level where we then need to be
unified again it's gonna take something
huge man it's gonna take something huge
and I sometimes worry that the media is
makes things so much worse than it is I
mean all they care about is dividing us
I strongly believe that I don't feel
like there's any gold and if anyone
still believes that the media has
humanity's best intention at heart I
think yeah I would love more proof of
that and if you want to drop a column
into that to help open my mind up to why
I'm you know might be wrong about that
then let me know but the media seems
should just be I mean the media is the
new Don King that's what I feel like you
know and in this corner and in this
corner they're just promoting it almost
seems like the end of the world that's
what it seems like to me sometimes
that's what they're trying to do what
they don't realize is that we are on to
them that people see that let's see past
that you know they see past that but I
agree how do we get to that next thing
that then brings us all together you
know there's so much division these days
but there's not as much as they make it
seem like on television all right let's
check into another call here thank you
guys for hitting the hotline hey Theo
this is Ryan I'm in Minnesota I just
wanna say I love your podcast man Thank
You Ryan I appreciate the call I love
Minnesota I was gonna
I II I don't want to tell you what
happened there
um word cracked me up daily I love it
absolutely love it
I was just wondering what do you think
about divorce because I've been married
for seven years and my wife my wife just
asked for separation she wants a divorce
she said we changed we don't have
anything in common anymore she got into
some spiritual stuff some weird healing
healing things with rocks and whatnot
I've shown them rocks now you know
what's crazy about rocks a lot of women
when they get on that rock they could
drift out of a marriage and now and and
I'm talking crack you know I'm talking
about you know that uh that Boulder
cocaine but I'm also talking about
geodes quartz you know quartzite
emeralds and all of that these ladies
get on these big rocks and next thing
you know you know they wearing uh you
know candy corn Underpants and you know
drinking their own breast milk out in
the woods and so that's another thing
you have to be careful of it's almost as
dangerous as getting into drugs is
people getting hopped up on their own
spirit you know people you know shaking
their own dandruff into a cup and then
you know freebase in a couple grams of
it either way that rock äj-- can can
affect a marriage either way you know
one way or the other that can really it
can really take some of these women down
so keep your eyes open keep your eyes
open that's what I tell you there keep
your eyes open homeward I don't
understand that we had a daughter about
well we had a daughter six years ago
almost to the day and she well happy
birthday to your daughter
onward D Coast left with her so we
haven't slept together for six years and
now she says that we've grown apart and
you know I reminded her that the reason
we've grown apart is because you haven't
slept with me for six years and she she
thinks it's just fine that this is what
people do our daughters gonna be fine
because everybody gets divorced these
days and I'm I'm not down with that the
alarm
I believe in marriage and I you know I
made a promise to God that I would stay
with her for you know through sickness
and health and all that all that stuff
so I just wonder what you think about
that
I appreciate your call bud okay so you
said your daughter your wife Coast's
left with your daughter I'm guessing me
that they you know after your daughter
was born it's been six years now that
they shared you know a bed together and
some parents choose to let their
children sleep with them some don't I
mean for six years and you're not in you
and your wife are not engaging in sex it
doesn't sound like for six years to me
outsider's perspective what would my my
just judgment be if it sounds like your
wife has some issues it sounds like your
wife you know maybe wanted a child and
is now just kind of riding this thing
out and that she instead of dealing with
whatever issues kind of she has you know
she's gotten into this you know these
new geodes or whatever are getting
hocked up hopped up on this you know
stalagtites or whatever collecting
collecting these you know stalagmite
chippings or whatever she's you know
picking up out in the woods or whatever
and praying to she's doing that as like
a sidestep you know instead of dealing
with her issue sometimes people instead
of dealing with our issues we just go
ahead deep into something wild you know
something really some type of chicanery
that keeps us bent up so we don't have
to straighten out sometimes it's easier
to just take a band instead of staying
straight you know it's sometimes it's
easier that's what it sounds like but
else it sounds like you guys might have
some codependency issues I don't know
but I do know this it sounds like an
unhealthy environment to be in right now
you know in the fact that you want to
stay in there and you're putting it on
God and stuff like that I respect that
but God wants you to be in a healthy
environment
you know God wants you to be able to be
healthy relationship wise if you're not
sexually active with your wife for six
years you know and she's not okay with
that she wants some separation she wants
some space I think now's a good time for
you to figure out what's going on with
you I really do
to be a good father I would say maybe
find a therapist or a group therapy and
start to share some of your feelings so
you can get to the bottom of what's
going on with you that's what I would
suggest man but also I don't [ __ ]
know bro you know I'm saying I'm afraid
to even get married do sitting at this
wedding this weekend I had so many
commitment issues and I had nothing to
do with it all I had to do was just you
know not be crazy you know not do
anything Wow not steal nothing you know
people used to steal a lot you know and
I was one of those people sometimes when
I was younger so just because you go to
a party doesn't mean that shit's yours
you know so you know I can only you know
give you so many thoughts because I
don't have so much experience with that
but those are just things from a
ballpark listener that's what it sounds
like to me
I appreciate your call let's uh let's
check in a little bit more here with
another call thank you for calling
what's up - yo this is Devin I'm from
Tampa Florida I had a question man and I
wanted to get your thoughts on this I
think you're a wise guy well I don't
know about that man but I appreciate you
calling Devin let's hear a little bit
more first time you know I I made love
with a with a woman man uh we were
dating for a while and I couldn't really
fit it in man and you know I don't have
a big Johnson by any means but you know
there's just something going on she had
some you know Trump Trump built
something in her in her vaginal canal
and so we have I said that small cavern
and that's that small cavern man some
women got that small cavern down there
you know it's more like a like a ear
hole than it is really a vagina some
ladies got that small cavern onward to
resort to but sex man and you know I put
it in her but that was the first time I
Wow buddy you know you just throwing it
out there like that attacking people's
buttocks you know the old lunch Hunter
himself huh okay so the first time you
had sexual intercourse this was he was
doing he was getting the erotic and he
was inside of this young lady's buttocks
onward Saxton after that man I
I guess I'm just into PUD stuff now and
I don't know if that messed with my head
but you know I find when I you know
start liking girls and stuff I want to
put it in their butt in it kind of ruin
stuff because you know they they don't
they don't want brown you know
we'll look buddy I mean some of us
getting a little graphic there I don't
know if you uh you know and I appreciate
it man I appreciate you calling yeah you
can't be out there hunting but I'll tell
you that straight up a lot of men out
there either sidestepping you know the
natural caverns of women you know the
appropriate caverns cavern one and made
us out there hunting but you know trying
to get you know trying to you know Hail
Mary trying to hit that Hail Mary you
know trying to get out you know be uh
you know that dark spelunker you know
trying to go Dexter you know what I'm
saying and you got to be careful man
because EE it's some type of addiction
you know I mean you have to think about
this the appropriate way the natural way
it is to happen is we nee Rajini that's
it that's the natural way so their
occasional you're gonna come across
somebody you know who likes something
different you like some new stylings you
can maybe work it out with somebody but
you need to get back to a place where
you're comfortable with that I think if
you want to be in a healthy way that's
what I think for me anyway
cuz look I'm telling you I'm coming to
you dudes watch a lot of pornography you
know out there seeing them digital ass
cheeks and all of that you know and the
titties flopping and things spraying out
in the distance people breaking
furniture and breaking vases and stuff
and doing sex and they got brothers out
there wearing a sneakers and they
[ __ ] you know and this shit's high
definition and people you know capturing
that ass you know people hide and
jewelry and everything and spilled milk
in each other's asses and everything and
you got to be careful man because that
stuff gets addictive and it's not
healthy I'm just gonna tell you that
right now it's not healthy so you know I
would say find ways to tone it down so
that if you think you're addicted to it
a
diction ain't cool man it's just not
healthy okay that's it dude all right
guys you've had a pretty long morning
here in our long afternoon whenever
you're listening to this yeah I got had
this one call that came in and this was
interesting to me and so I wanted to
share this share this with you guys
right here let's take a peek at this one
right here hey brother it's Christian
from Bakersfield don't look it up it's
not important I hear it's dry
Bakersfield thank you for calling
Christian homeward Doug Lee it stinks um
I don't want to talk about Las Vegas I
want to talk about NFL players kneeling
huge Seahawks fan doesn't bother me
we go in the game in November not
selling my tickets
you heard him he's going to a game in
November he's not selling his tickets if
the products good he'll go back if the
products are not good maybe he won't put
your money where your mouth is you know
put your mom wherever you put your money
that's where things are gonna change
home where there was more of a is more
than an underlying an underlying topic
that I find to be prevalent throughout
all of your podcast which is this search
for happiness man you know and I have
found and this is just my opinion
is that happiness is something that we
already are happiness isn't something
that you you achieve you know it's not
it's not like a goal or you know if you
have that baby if you have that car if
you have that job you have this much
money you'd be happy I would be happy if
this of yeah if that like everyone is
talking like this but man you're already
happy the problem is that people tend to
just pile some of the [ __ ] on top of
themselves bad relationships bad
situations bad jobs you know jobs that
they know that they could do better or
job that they're not happy and they just
stick it out with a [ __ ] boss and the
guy that's you know
groping your ass or winking at you
customers are [ __ ] across from the
cubicle
that's this dude Charmin this place I
used to work at man this cat Sherman his
eyesight was bad dude and he'd grab
anything that was warm bro I don't care
if it was a damn if it was a loaf of
bread or if somebody's nipple or thigh
didn't matter boy that dude with grope
he was a real group or and I think he
came from a group of gropers I think he
came from a group of gropers I think in
his house
they were probably people that couldn't
see well his whole family when you can't
see well you got to grow you got to grow
up to know who this even is you know I'm
saying you have to grow up first before
you hug before you wish somebody happy
birthday you don't want to make sure you
wishing the wrong person happy birthday
and it's not even the right family
member so sometime you got to grow up
first to get a little bit of feeling you
know you got to hit that body Braille
you got to hit that body Braille and
feel somebody down and you catch a mole
or you catch a you know patch a hair
something that's unique to them but I
like this call and I'm here listen to
continue to listen to it with you guys
just a little bit longer let's get back
to Christian Thank You Christian and
they don't realize that all this is
chipping away know what you already are
you're happy by default is it's
relationships that are hard to break
away from even if it's family members if
if relationships don't add value if
situations don't add value to your life
you have to be strong enough as a person
to completely cut it off let go of all
the [ __ ] and you know it's [ __ ]
social media stop looking at the [ __ ]
news it's depressing get off Facebook
delete it delete everything and just
live your life and enjoy the sunset and
enjoy your family enjoy your kids your
dog's your [ __ ] whatever herd of
elephants whatever you have going on in
backyard yeah herd of elephants in the
backyard it got a little twisty there at
the end he might be invested in some of
those geodes you know them geological
stag tied to the magical you know
magical dice are playing with warlocks
and wizards or wizards and warlocks but
I love I love I love this guy's message
for him and that's why I wanted to wrap
up today's episode with this call
because you know there's there's some
righteousness in there you know
sometimes the the thinking is that we
get tricked into thinking that we aren't
happy to begin with you know that our
natural default isn't happiness and and
that's true and we pile all this other
stuff on and we stay in it you know
right now if I really ask myself you
know what am I in that I don't want to
be in what situations what things and
work what you you know interactions with
other humans loved ones family anyone
what am i involved in that I don't want
to be in and that I can get out of and
that would just probably set me free I
bet there's a list of things of good
things I'm not saying you know you just
leave your family you know if you have
responsibilities you have
responsibilities and you take care of
those but outside of that you know what
are we [ __ ] milling around in you
know somebody's out here collecting
shoes and [ __ ] you know I mean Michael
Jordan has all the shoes in the world he
invented half of them you know and he's
still gonna he's his lights gonna come
to an end one day
you know she so just like that Coleman
is a lot of happiness there's already a
lot of happiness sometimes it's just the
fact that we stack all this stuff of the
stuff on us and the social media you
know I go back to uh to that kid from a
hometown that Barry who got hit by that
icicle and at the time they didn't
really have social media but his mom was
so busy worried about telling everybody
everything that she didn't focus on what
was important she was too busy out
shouting from the rooftops you know this
and that and you know mother nature's a
[ __ ] and he could have gone pro he
didn't have no skills lady but he
certainly could have probably had a much
better relationship with his mother if
she would have focused not on what at
the time was there social media just
yelling
you know focus just on loving her son
and getting back to the things that are
important and celebrating living man you
know it's been a wild week a loss you
know it really has on a lot of levels
and you know I didn't mean this episode
to be a little bit of a downer but I've
just had some of these things going
through my life and some of them are
going through you guys's lives you know
and no we don't we shouldn't be afraid
to live but at the same time we have to
live you know if we're just gonna sit
there and fight we're just gonna give in
to the divisiveness then we're good then
we then we've already lost you know
sometimes we as people have to rise
above whatever's going on around us even
though it's the the stuff that's around
us is made to be so addictive
we can't shake this [ __ ] man people
talking about cigarettes are addictive
everything man there's nine there's nine
varieties the cigarettes in every
different variety every interaction
Twitter you know sugar six pornography
you know crack geode stalagtites people
out there wife's buying crystals off the
internet trying to change their life
enough and meanwhile the sharing a bed
every night with their six-year-old
daughter and making her husband sleep in
another room and the husband acting like
everything is okay what it whoa come on
guys you know and I'm not preaching at
you I'm preaching with you because these
are things I need to hear myself say man
you know the things that might in my
life where I'm you know I'm just just
going along you know maybe I'm not
making the best moves for myself or
making the best choices you know and I
think I just got to be reminded so I
appreciate you guys getting together
with me to remind myself you know and
and and sharing this time together
because I don't want to end up in the
dark arts man it's so easy but I'm out
here I'm on the frontlines in my own
life and that's where I'm gonna stay man
and I'm gonna celebrate dude
you know i'ma celebrate living man
that's what I'm gonna do and I want to
say you know God bless you Ralphie and
my thoughts and my prayers are with you
and your soul and your family Ralph
Duren Ralph Duren it almost sounds like
a redneck clothing company oh I got this
Ralph Duren I got this Ralph Duren
but a beautiful man dude and I hope your
spirit lives our lives on and so many
people do it it almost seems like you
infected millions you know and I think
maybe you sometimes you your weight you
had to be that big I don't know if a
skinny man could have pulled that job
off but uh but thank you dude you
inspire me man
you inspired me to reach out to other
young comedians who who probably need to
know that you know that they're not
alone if they're second-guessing
themselves and I'm gonna do that man I'm
gonna do that I'm gonna remember to do
that in your honor and I don't even
think I'm gonna have to think to
remember it because I think my feelings
are gonna are gonna remind me you know
but you guys be good man I know we're a
little bit all over the place but just
trying to learn as we go and thank you
guys you guys be good hit the hotline
you want to be a part of the show nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three and and we'll add a little bit
more show here on to the patreon and all
patreon or I'll see you guys there in a
bit
god bless y'all if you believe in God if
you don't then just bless y'all man
but somebody bless y'all just don't live
alone be good to yourselves I bet you
deserve
[Music]
the brain
celebrate man
[Music]
we all die